à à
à à à à
ừ ừ
à à à à à à
ừ ừ à à
anh alo alo anh alo
em tự nhiên bị mất mạng các bạn nghe thấy mình nói rượu
Ừ Từ tự nhiên bị sập sờ chim nhỏ xập sờ chim nhưng mà dung thì mít thì vẫn được
đúng không số trực tiếp ngày hôm nay
thôi Cứ tiếp tục mình mình đưa ra là mình có quan tâm mình mình có quay lại
để các bạn khác xem tham khảo thôi chứ thực ra là quan trọng là mình mình bảo vệ và đúng không không không không quan
tâm cái Sochi lắm chứ chưa xe để lại đi
ừ ừ
ờ ờ thì thì mình đã nói rồi thì mình mình
chữa cho các mình chữa cho cá nhòm nhá thì có nhỏ giúp khi hiện để mà hôm bảo
vệ thật thì sẽ thuyết trình và trả lời câu hỏi các thứ có thể mình
sẽ hỏi lại cô cũng nhưng có thể sẽ có mới này nhớ chuẩn bị sẵn trước và mình sẽ hỏi những cái gì nữa và không không
sửa cốt không Không có Không cập nhật là gì cả gần như giữ nguyên thôi chứ khi
mình bảo sửa thì mới sửa nhé tránh việc kiểu hôm bảo vệ thì nó sẽ không kịp
nhà chia sẻ lại màn hình đi em Em thấy chưa Ok Ok
nhạc karaoke tiếp tục đến
đường Bạn ở đâu đấy thì học hóa đơn Nói chung mà anh
Nghĩa kiểu về sau nếu mà muốn sửa thì nên sửa là như thế tiếp theo thì anh
thấy có bảng ở kia là bảo nhà khách hàng đúng không bằng khách hàng thì có tóc em
để làm gì nhỉ ở Thái Lan đã lưu mật khẩu
em không có quen đâu phải để lưu mật khẩu mật khẩu có cột viên mà
em để để lăng để em đưa để xác thật ra làm sao
nó khỏi các đăng nhập quốc kìa giờ không Ok Thế còn bạn for này làm gì
để phát là quên mật khẩu quên mật khẩu đúng không Ok
Ở đây anh thấy có vài cái anh chữa rồi thì các bạn cũng làm có vẻ ổn
nhưng mà ở đây có một cái có bạn vừa nãy có nói có bạn hỏi
để anh thử hỏi lại em xem trả lời nhá Mấy cái á áo ren đỏ ở trong bảng kohgendo Tại sao
lại có va tra 20 Ừ
tại vì giới tính thì phường nam nữ và trẻ em là nam
Ok anh hiểu rồi đấy hết ấy hỏi ạ hiện tại sao em có render ở trong bảng admin
hoặc là khách hàng thì lại là bit
cái này cái này là do tính của khách hàng với giới tính của sản phẩm khác
nhau khác khác nhau chỗ nào nhỉ bởi bạn Tuấn Khanh thì chỉ có nam nữ
thôi còn bên sản phẩm của em thì tính là buồn Mà
anh chị nữ cả nam và nữ gặp lại chị ạ
Anh không hiểu tại sao không làm chung luôn cả bến khách hàng ăn mì nữa đấy thứ
nhất nha thứ hai đó là thực ai Nếu mà giả sử em còn bảo em ra em trả lời câu
rồi Em có thể nói là kẹp có thể bé nam ái nữ cũng được kiểu phụ nữ đàn ông
trung niên gì gì đó thì nó sẽ hợp lý hơn nhưng cũng chính vì thế thì thành ra là
thuộc cái ấy thì cần lấy hoàn toàn thể Vứt vào trong phần thể loại được nó cá III thể loại
tốt hơn là sách nó ra thành cái giới tính đương nhiên thì anh hiểu ý em và là
sản phẩm nên có thể loại riêng này và giới tính riêng nhưng mà ý anh à bản
chất nó vẫn ở thể loại thôi Nên là một sản phẩm có thể có nhiều thể loạn
thì nó sẽ ổn hơn việc tách ra thành Ừ đúng rồi bạn có bạn cũng bình luận kia
đó là nó là thể loại nên thành ra là em nó làm thể loại và thời loại và tính với
cái cô đắp thì nó là một n n thì nó sẽ ổn hơn thay vì kiểu Để như này Đấy cách
sửa thì nó sẽ thấy Nghĩa là em sẽ tạo bảng trung gian ra để mà lưu lại mối
quan hệ giữa hai hàng ngày nó hợp lý hơn nhờ thôi Bây giờ thì làm rồi thì chẳng có sửa thì cả đúng không Nhưng mà rút
kinh nghiệm về này đã tao đây này anh nhớ anh không diệt cái này đâu nhá sáng
nên Không việc cái đảo liên quan thì người giới tính kiểu này luôn thì các bạn sửa ra bay ở sở ở đây nhá
rồi à Ok bây giờ xanh thì mua luôn nhỉ để mua cho
anh từ khách hàng trước đi Xem con bò
à à anh thương em đừng vội xa
hay là cho em khách hàng à hôm nay là trang chủ
trên đây là Trang Collection có lấy xe thì nó chia thành là Trang main
menu với nó thì nó có ba cho tính chính thôi
anh ở đây thì có sắp xếp Giá
i i i tờ tiêu nghe cảm xúc
các
bác dùng dùng Ajax nóng chứ không phải lại ra nó em dùng hết các
phép để trả tiền trên em không chịu đánh dấu số trang em dùng xem thêm
Ok để xem thêm này thì em có làm chỗ này
chỗ sợ về với chỗ xem hóa đơn ạ
Em thử đặt sản phẩm đi xe
à à anh em giới hạn tối đa là 10 sản phẩm
một loại sản phẩm này thì chỉ đặt được số lượng tối đa là 10 rồi với 15 đặt thêm à
ừ ừ
à à
cha mẹ chúng ta là trận số lượng trong ngày em
đặt hàng luôn à ừ ừ
ừ ừ à à
à à ừ ừ ừ ừ
vẻ đẹp
đang ở đâu hay không có sở thị Đơn
ừ ừ cho dù trang Cái này là đang trên tài
khoản cho nó gọn thi có cập nhật thông tin đổi mật khẩu ạ
Ừ ok bến khách hàng còn tính năng gì nữa không [âm nhạc]
Này thì lúc trước là em Em bên lỗi xong thì em cho tại lại cho em mà Mấy bữa nay
em xui ý bằng Xem clip mà em em
em tặng phạm tắt cái tiếng từ kênh YouTube để đỡ ổn
rồi em Em sang bên đấy khách hàng xong hết rồi đúng không
ưu điểm thì còn tính năng quên mật khẩu Ok Ok rồi rồi Thôi thôi thôi sẽ không
cần kỹ năng nữa đâu Ờ rồi bên An Minh Thời Để lâu anh sẽ để em lên thì mình ngưng trệ nhất à
anh [âm nhạc]
alo em Em mở mấy trí nhớ em tắt máy rồi Ừ em ấn nút tắt máy cơ
anh Alo Alo ạ Ừ
để em ấy lại khi ngày đang xuất ở đầu tiên thì
ở đầu tiên thì mình sẽ là trang tóc tiên của bên admin thì mình sẽ có là ca nhạc
yêu em quên mật khẩu khi sex
thì mình sẽ có phần nhớ mật khẩu đây là sẽ
nhớ và công ty khi bé trai làm sao à
Em thì lúc nào giờ mình sẽ vào đơn hàng mà xem bên này là của bên Super admin
ý là sẽ xem ngân hàng của Xem tình trạng dương vật gì trơn á
À hôm nay sản phẩm thì có có xem từng sản phẩm của tiếp sản phẩm
thì bấm vô tình sản phẩm sẽ có là số lẻ
tuần theo tháng các thông tin của sản phẩm thì ấn vô
sản phẩm Anh tên sản phẩm về bên đây
So sánh sản phẩm thì ý đây xã Chung Bà
xã bấm xác nhận anh ở bên nhà sản xuất là có danh sách của
nhà sản xuất anh bấm vô tình nhạc Sóc Sờ sẽ có thư tình của những giấc mơ
ở cấp 3
của bên nhà sản xuất đó e k có
nhà cấp 5 tuần à
từ nhỏ quá trên cái tên nó không có được
ở bên đây là Tên Em nhạc sống ở bên đây là có danh sách của
ở Ninh Bình ở súp Superman thì không có quyền truy cập được
có truy cập bên pin
viết hàng tôi còn nhớ đây sẽ sửa thông tin nha à
à à ở bên này là thêm nhân viên rồi Sáng sáng
nhân viên con cá được Superman à
à à ở bên em chưa Còn cái này là phần tìm kiếm
ý Em chỉ là tìm kiếm tên xã hội online à
Ừ Ok Xem lại độ hào rồi đổi mật khẩu
thôi em thôi em alo nói gì ca nhạc dương xanh
anh alo alo alo alo
quay quay lại đơn hàng đi Bấm bấm vào xem một đơn mà Đấy anh nghe
đẹp 300 bấm vào xem chi tiết đơn này không
quên rồi à
ca nhạc ok không là nút duyệt là nó vì ra ngoài
luôn đã phải thoát ra ngoài 3 nốt diệt Làm ơn
dẹp nó bên pin U21 bọn kia thôi
ok nghĩa là Superman không duyệt Dạ không không hay lắm nha ok rồi này
ta đổ nhạc còn tính năng gì nữa không nghỉ à
Em à chị hãy bên anh ạ
a pin bản sản phẩm thì chỉ có sản phẩm lại đơn hàng không
sẽ hơn đúng không Ok Ok
còn còn gì Em muốn chia sẻ được không nhỉ à à
đi tạm bỏ qua cái vụ kết luận với hướng mở rộng cho bảo vệ thật thì nói sau nhé
Bây giờ trả hết hết chưa hết tính năng Chưa ạ
Nếu hết rồi thôi Ok Cảm ơn nhóm mình cho nhóm Thế đi học nhóm mình thì được tiếng
rồi à Ừ Ok em nhé
Tạm tắt rồi cả nhóm tiếp theo nhỉ à
à à à à
Ừ đúng rồi Khá là khá mất thời gian mà Thế nên mấy ông hình dung ngồi trước một
ngày tôi mất luôn cả ngày chủ nhật thì ngồi chấm 20 nhóm thì nó tệ như thế nào nhưng mà đấy là
ở trên trường tôi thì lui khi là tôi cho thịt Kids vẫn cả hỗ trợ các bạn để làm
nhanh được còn bây giờ tôi đang mua phần là đồ ăn bột nữa này ra nó hơi bị lâu các từ thứ
thầy có nhận xét đã có thực ra là khi bảo vệ thật thì tôi sẽ có ghi chấm lại
nhận xét các thứ tôi sẽ chấm lại theo cái phom nó có cái form để mà chấm form
ấy Thực ra là có cái mục điểm giao diện đấy nhưng mà tôi sẽ chỉ
chấm mức tương đối với cái giao diện vì đón một thì tôi bảo không quan trọng nó sẽ tội trả tôi sẽ gửi các bạn cái form
sao các bạn người nhắc tôi nhá ngọn lớp trưởng nhanh được đấy tôi sẽ gửi các bạn
cài form mẫu cái khung điểm nó có một cái không đỉa
hai chấm các bạn sẽ dựa theo tiêu chí gì Ừ không sao
buổi bảo vệ thủ thì chắc chắn là ở anh lại ra mong muốn có một nhóm gây đầy đủ
lỗi để mà do nhóm khác nhìn vào để giúp cai nghiện Thế mới bảo vệ thử đưa nhờ
hơi mất thời gian một tí Nếu mà nói chung hò ai ai thấy ổn thì ngồi xem
tiếp đúng không còn ai không phải việc của mình và cảm thấy nó mất thời gian quá thì có thể xem lại sau tôi nhanh sau
không có trọng mà đúng không
anh không Tao không giáo bảo vệ thật thì ra ánh sẽ cùng thời hạn thời gian hơn còn bảo vệ thù thì các bạn càng gây cả
nhiều lỗi càng tốt thì biết hôm bảo vệ thật rút kinh nghiệm không tất cả cùng rút kinh nghiệm chứ không phải mỗi nhóm
Anh Dũng hiện đúng không nhóm 13 có lên không nhỉ
bộ đồ ăn ở đồ ăn tết đấy à
dự đoán 1 ở trường thì cần giao diện à Thế à dở rồi bởi vì mình có dậy ra diện
đâu mình sẽ các bạn về lập trình mà chữa bệnh dễ Thiết kế đâu
313 có đây không cho bạn chiến đã bận
à à Rồi Rồi quên mình quên nhóm 3 vậy Nhóm body
anh alo Ừ bắt đầu thôi em ạ
Anh nhớ em chỉ có một cái viên à Ok em Không sao một thành viên chuyển
được thì được cộng thêm điểm không phải trẻ không mấy ai cả
ừ ừ à à
mọi người nhìn thấy màn hình chưa Rồi em mở ấn F5 ở chế độ chính chiếu đấy
à Dạ em chào thầy và các bạn thì em
xin tự rượu em là sẽ vào đến từ nhóm 5 ạ thì hôm nay em xin trình bày về
đề tài của nhóm là thiết kế website abcshop
khi mà vấn đề đưa ra là đặt ta đã công ty cần một Website để hỗ trợ khách hàng
xem sản phẩm là có thể xem giá số lượng sản phẩm và hình ảnh ạ và khách hàng có
thể theo dõi đơn hàng của mình một cách kích hoạt trên internet A và hỗ trợ nhân viên bán hàng cần lưu
trữ thông tin ngân hàng anh xem em đã có phân tích và đưa ra các
đối tượng của hệ thống là cùng có khách hàng chưa có tài khoản khách hàng đã có tài khoản khách hàng Khách hàng đã đăng
ký tài khoản và nhân viên và quản lý ạ ạ Và nếu mà khách hàng chưa có tài khoản
thì chị sẽ bỏ tính năng là đăng ký và đăng nhập xem danh sách các sản phẩm và xem
chi tiết sản phẩm và có thể tìm kiếm sản phẩm a đối với khách hàng đã có tài khoản thì
có thể đăng nhập và đăng xuất Xem thông tin và chỉnh sửa thông tin của
chị khách hàng đó tìm kiếm sản phẩm
để xem danh sách sản phẩm và chi tiết sản phẩm tương tự nhiên là khách hàng chưa tài khoản
đối với nhân viên thì đem chia sẻ là chỉ có thêm sửa sản phẩm
và nhà sản xuất và dù đơn hàng có thể là tìm kiếm đơn hàng theo mã hóa đơn
Anh bảo quản lý thì cũng tương tự nhiên nhân viên nhưng mà sẽ có quyền là xóa
sản phẩm và xã nhà sản xuất anh không về sử dụng của nhóm em là
Gmail share equip và thiết bị và Maxwell ạ
anh ở đây sau đây là sơ đồ sơ đồ thẻ I play video
chị xem chỉ làm mà Cái này thì đã nhân viên sẽ vượt hóa đơn và nhưng mà sẽ
không lưu lệ lưu lại là có nhân viên nào đã Việt hóa đơn nhé
Ừ Ok Ok Cứ tiếp tục đi vợ tổng quan về cơ sở dữ liệu
anh ở đây thì có bảo quên mật khẩu nhưng mà Ừ nhưng mà cái chỗ phần gửi mail đấy à
Bọn em chưa phát triển được cho em Em lấy bánh có ảnh giá rẻ nhưng mà vẫn
chưa phát triển được tính năng đấy ạ A và đầu tiên là về sản phẩm thì sẽ
chị sẽ có các không ở các bảng như này ở các cụ liên hệ và
sẽ có phần bảng đánh giá của sản phẩm đấy ạ theo sản phẩm mình sẽ có từ một
sản phẩm sẽ có 1 là ở nhà sản xuất ạ vào sản phẩm sẽ được
nối với bảo là hóa đơn thông qua bảo chúng ta này để lưu lại là một hóa đơn
sẽ có khi mở khóa đơn mua thì sẽ có nhiều các
loại sản phẩm và số lượng [âm nhạc] Tại đây có khách hàng thì có thể đánh
giá sản phẩm mã sản phẩm qua bảo của Jack greetings
Anh ở bảng admin đi Em không có lỗi với bạn à có hóa đơn để duyệt hóa đơn để lấy lại
nhưng mà vẫn truyền lại ừ ừ 300 song song song để modi sao lại một
cái cái nồi súp gà tâm bên này anh thấy cũng có bản rồi cứ xanh để mua thì có gì
anh hỏi à à
bí thư viện của trang web
[âm nhạc] đầu tiên thì em sẽ đăng nhập vào
à à ừ ừ ê ê
thì mình sẽ phải đăng nhập vào thì mới sinh
được sản phẩm vào giỏ hàng ạ Em sẽ thêm một số sản phẩm giỏi
A và đúng hả chống các phần cái mình đã
ký thì sẽ không cần điền địa chỉ ạ Nếu mà trống địa chỉ thì chắc phải quay lại
vào phần ở trang chủ đề file này để thiết địa chị
ạ ở miền Trung nhưng mà đây đã đầy đủ địa chỉ nên là vậy chi tiết chịu thi có thể
tiến hành đào tạo ở không không không Nhiều mà hơi bị nhầm đấy vì là người
người đặt có thể khác với người nhận mà
à Dạ vâng nghe thì nếu mà khách hàng này chỉ có
thể đạt được vì thế mà người đã khác thì chị có sửa được không địa chỉ được không sửa bên
địa chính sẽ tải ạ Và nếu mà đăng đặt hàng thì có thể gửi được
ừ ừ Ừ Ok Ô
Ừ thôi thôi Ờ xong bên bến khách hàng còn tính năng gì không ạ
chị đã có tính năng ở đánh giá sản phẩm em à ok rồi còn có tính năng gì nữa
à à em có tìm kiếm ở trên này nữa nếu mà tìm
kiếm mà à
ex2 kế hoạch trang chủ nữa ngắm vợ ấn vào thì sẽ ra chi tiết sản phẩm karaoke
cũng sẽ nhà nha chỉ tìm kiếm trụ Ok sang bên ăn mini
ừ ừ [âm nhạc] Anh lập thế nào phần anh ạ
à à em vẫn để là thích
ừ ừ à à từ khóa phim ma các công nghiệp sản xuất
và sản phẩm
ừ ừ Ừ có gì bất hạnh rồi
ừ ừ ở
thời thủ diệt anh cô đơn em à em ở đâu vợ
anh em sẽ rưới hàng này Ừ nhưng mà phải gửi lại thì nó mới mất
thì nó sẽ vào đơn hàng đã chuyện
Ừ ok ok Chồng cũng chị Nói chung là cũng tích hợp thêm à a Chắc tao thứ giao diện
để trông ổn khi con còn gì nữa em có tìm kiếm mở đơn hàng này à
xe hơi mất câu hỏi cứ phải bấm vào cái Menu có phải mở lại menu nhà em có cách
nào để cho nó kiểu biết cách để nó kiểu cố định theo cái đường Linh không Nghĩa
giả sử em vào ngày order for lease kia cái tổng quan đến Hàn đúng không em cho
nó 1 cái Active để nó giữ được cái kiểu tự động mở me núi được mà
Dạ vâng cái này em mới làm hồi chiều đấy là mình đang ở trong cái đứa này thì cái
này sẽ phải mở ra đúng rồi mới làm hồi chiều á Chiều nay vẫn côi cút
ạ bây giờ hạn chế không đậu một cốt nữa không phải lỗi đấy ngồi làm tài liệu
thôi không ngồi cốt này nhá Giờ vợ anh anh thấy các tính năng về các bạn khá lâu ổn rồi Mình mình làm kiếm hết quá
nhiều rồi nữa thôi tạm rồi Con con con gì muốn quay đâu
ừ ừ Ừ cái nào tài khoản Superman thì mình
chỉ mình sẽ thêm vào Các tướng quân đối với cả cái Nếu mà nhân viên thì chắc là vẫn
thiên về nghiên tin mới À mà thôi sao tao thôi ok ok rồi thì anh
anh góp ý 1 tí là thứ nhất à cái vừa nãy trình bày sẽ lại anh thấy rất là có một
chỗ viết tắt nó danh sách thể bây giờ ghét đấy thì đấy đúng rồi
Ừ cái trên đấy Đúng rồi thì thứ nhất là không ở được lên cái tát ở trong slide
thứ hai là tính năng làm chưa hoàn thiện chưa làm đấy thì tạm ẩn đi Ít nhất ở
trong sở Lai có thể trong Word thì có thể cập nhưng mà trong slide nên ẩn đi kiểu gì anh không thì không có thể nó
ghi vào trong phần hướng mở rộng ở phần kết luận là đang làm dở Cái gì đó cũng được vì thực ra là
một mình Hoa Và thậm chí làm hai người nhưng mà vẫn nhiều tính năng tham quá Làm nhiều tính năng nói chưa đủ ra đấy
thì các bạn không nên được gặp phải trong slide đấy à A được Ok Vậy đợi
những cái anh góp ý còn về cơ bản thì anh phải đầy đủ tính năng các thứ có vẻ ổn thôi được rồi Đương nhiên là trải
nghiệm người dùng thì chắc là vẫn con chưa được mượt chưa được mượt lắm Bởi vì ví dụ như em bảo đây đúng không Thì em
biết được em có vài chỗ không chưa ổn lắm rồi đúng không Nhưng mà thôi Cái đấy thế khó ổn
rồi không không sửa cốt nha bây giờ tạm không động của cô nữa chị ngồi chăm chút
tài liệu xong rồi luyện thi trình thì thôi Một tuần nữa bảo vệ ở đâu thứ bảy
này có thể bảo vệ thật rồi nha trò chơi nhà không Ừ Ok Cảm ơn em rồi nhóm tiếp theo nhỉ à
ở nhóm 14 nhà ở
ở nhóm 14 đâu rồi bài
13 + 14 lên hát à ừ ừ
cả nhóm bắt đầu đi Chỗ ở tôi bảo rồi buổi hôm nay là chuyện có thể hai tiếng
mỗi buổi 2 tiếng đấy nhiều bông sẽ thấy hơi mất kiên nhẫn một tí tôi tôi không quan tâm với việc có bao nhiêu người xem
đâu thế nên là thành ra là mấy ông thoát chết thì tội không quan tâm tôi chỉ quan
tâm có nhóm có ở đây thôi Ừ Ok Ok em bắt đầu đi ạ
mở màn hình chưa chưa chưa chưa em ơi
anh cho số liệu ừ có khi là có một vài trình duyệt là nó phải em bé phải chạy
lại quyền ăn mini em quên để quên mất chân xe
giờ đây Alo Được rồi Được rồi Em bắt đầu em ạ
sau đây là phần trình bày gọi nhóm 14 đồ án một thì đề tài 7 đến 14 là cà phê
Italia Brand name là Coffee ở thành viên ở 54 bao gồm em làm cái
thái sơn nhóm trưởng và bạn tâm Chấn Vũ là thành viên của nhóm Á vì lý do chọn đề tài thì
thứ nhất để đúng với cái nhập khẩu của
đồ án thì khi Coffee sẽ là một cái Grand phục vụ đa dạng đồ uống và bánh ngọt Tuy
nhiên thì mặc mặc dù nhóm có bậc quán có không gian cho khách dùng
món tại chỗ nhưng xu hướng mở rộng của nhóm là phát triển về dịch vụ đặt hàng
online cho mua mang về vì vậy thì quán rất cần có một cái hệ thống thuận tiện
để triển khai cái mô hình kinh doanh mới này ở thời điểm hiện tại thì cái mô hình hệ thống hàng thứ nhất là hệ thống web
cho phép khách hàng có thể lựa chọn mua hàng và đặt hàng các kênh Sóng quản lý
đơn hàng sản phẩm nhân sự dễ dàng hơn Tết với việc phương pháp thủ công hiện
tại đó là giải quyết trên giấy tờ cũng như là Excel thì nó rất là bất tiện
em có về hóa đơn và hồ sơ vì vậy là khi mà mọi thứ đều được tự động hóa thì sẽ
phải giải quyết được những vấn đề tồn đọng của công tác truyền thống nhưng mà lý do thực sự thì nó là để cái
thành p mày có lẽ Tác dụng thì kéo sử dụng phép
t 7.4 Java Script S5 Serious Mass
pl7 đối tượng sử dụng thì là khách hàng bao nhiêu cầu mua đặt mua online của quán quản lý nhân viên của quán
đức đã sử dụng khách hàng thì sẽ có khả năng sẽ có
chức năng là tham khảo menu tham khảo các sản phẩm xem giá xem đánh xem giá
xem chi tiết xe môtô và thêm vào giỏ hàng và đặt hàng quản lý nhân viên thì
có thể quản lý đơn hàng còn đi sản phẩm quản lý tài khoản khách tới đây thì em xin mời thành viên nhóm
bệnh khi bé trình bày qua về một số chức năng của khách hàng của bên giờ gọi điện khách
hàng
Alo bạn ơi à
à à
ừ ừ ừ ừ
cho mọi người ấy giờ
OK em Em trình bài đấy em
về các chức năng khách hàng Ừ thì có 4 chức năng chính là quản lý
tài khoản xem năm phẩm quản lý do hàng và đặt hàng ạ
Ê mày chỉ biết ăn bạn có tài khoản thì bao gồm đăng ký và đăng nhập thông tin
và giữ nhà tao còn đang xuất sản phẩm có Xem tổng quan
đi tìm kiếm theo
à cuối cùng là đặt hàng thì có thể sử dụng thông tin à
Ồ thông tin nuôi trong tài khoản hoặc là tự điều này thì đều
khi tất cả những chiếc khăn - quản lý tài khoản thì người dùng Ừ ông có tài khoản được có thể sử dụng
anh em C H O à à
Ừ Ok em nó về màn hình đấy em ạ
tí nữa hai người đang xem hai màn hình ai để như anh để mỗi một màn hình gì vậy
ạ anh khóc ra đây thì tiếp theo Thế là em
sẽ trình bày một số chức năng của quản lý nhân viên gọi cuộc gọi nhân viên thì với bên quản lý và nhân viên thì
nhân viên có thể nhân viên có thể xem thông tin cái Xem
thông tin cá nhân chỉnh sửa thông tin được ảnh đại diện để mật khẩu xem các đơn đặt hàng và chỉnh sửa trả
đơn hàng nhân viên là chủ quyền trưởng thành cá nhân hành hạ xem sản phẩm và chỉ được phép chỉnh sửa
các sản phẩm và được xem các tài khoản khách hàng mới bên quản lý thì cũng
tương tự nhiên lên nhân viên có khả năng Xem thông tin cá nhân chỉnh sửa thông tin tưởng đại diện và được mật khẩu xem các đơn đặt hàng chỉ phải trạng thái
và có khả năng xóa đơn hàng đầy đủ chức năng xem thêm sửa xóa sản phẩm xem sửa và xóa tài khoản khách hàng ra
thì lúc nào em có suy nghĩ đến việc là khóa là khách hàng nhưng em nghĩ là sợ
Xóa thì nhanh hơn đã có thể xem chi tất cả bộ nhân viên quản lý thêm nhân viên hoặc quản lý sửa
vật cá nhân viên vé số được thể của nhóm em thì
cái này đó là cái ảnh của em đây là em không Cái phần cái thần gió thì nó sẽ
không có nữa ăn nó xóa nhưng mà lại với máy ảnh cũ cho em ra lấy nhầm ảnh fast
app thì mày phải không đốm tàn tâm không không đổi tên là hết quan hệ giữa cái
phần booking không có chỉ có start các order và chậm thì quan hệ giữa các tầng
mơ vào order thì là 1n và quan hệ giữa R và N N N N lấy hình ảnh hưởng cái ảnh
khác chưa phân rõ phần booking để ra xe không có
về cơ sở dữ liệu thì trong cơ sở dữ liệu để sẽ có 5 bảng bảng tát sẽ bao gồm các
thông tin như ID in dần đêm nên Email ở
I fall chander run và Avatar
Đặng giữa do mối quan hệ giữa anh và ở order là đời nên cần các bạn Trung Giang
là alderfer trong lại sẽ lưu lại ID The Body wash it
applies ô sin l size của sản phẩm được
chọn cái này thì có idi trần bay điôxin vào size sẽ là khóa chính của bảng này
Ừ em có thể giải thích cho các bạn anh Anh thì từng
nghe qua nay rồi nhưng em cứ giải thích lại cho các bạn về mấy cái cột ở trong bảng ai tầm rồi không sợ cho vợ trong
bạn ai tờ ai tầm thì IC thì gọi em sẽ để áo sơ mi jean rồi
đêm là các sản phẩm I miss ảnh ba cái thế này là size là giá của ba cái sai
của nó thì Trọng có thể đặt nó bằng 0 Tức là không tồn tại cái sai đấy đứt
kiếp duration thì sẽ là mô tả categories thì là cái danh mục của nó rồi ai và Su
Su là hai cái cột mà chắc là bạn có thắc mắc nhiều nhất Thì cái này nó để thể hiện rằng là sản phẩm này có được có
tính năng là thêm đá hoặc là thêm đường hay không chỉ vậy thật thì cái này thì nó không có
ảnh hưởng đến giá sản phẩm nên là nó cũng không có trong cái order đi theo
ở nhưng mà Nếu giả sử đặt à cài đặt nóng sản phẩm nóng thì lưu lại
trong truyện trong sản phẩm nóng thì nó sẽ được lưu lại phần Ocean đấy thì có
bạn có thắc mắc ỉa Giả sử là đặt một cái đấy chị ơi Chưa ạ Em sẽ quan trọng này
U30 đá 70 đường có đạt được không lưu lại trong
thì sẽ có giải thích kỹ hơn
Ừ ừ Thực ra là có bạn cũng đang nói việc và đá với
đường nó không phù hợp với cái việc lưu lại hạn một cột trong đây nhưng mà cái
này Đấy Đó chỉ là kích hoạt xem sản phẩm này có khả năng là được thêm đá và thực thêm đường hay không Tức là ví dụ lên
với sản phẩm với sản phẩm như nào cả hai nóng thì cái tính năng chọn phần trăm đá
nó sẽ bị khóa lại thì cái này để lưu lại cho nó có bị khóa lại không được Ừ anh anh anh thì anh hiểu cái đấy nhưng mà
anh đang nói là kiểu về về cơ bản thì thiết kế ra bay thì à ở đây nửa nửa được nữa không được ở đây
là tiện tiện ở trong người việc và em đang bán các loại đồ uống mà nó phù hợp với mày cái tủ này và còn những cái thì
nó sẽ không không có cả những cái đấy ảnh anh đang chưa hình dung được sẽ có
cái sản phẩm nó không có cả hai cái đấy cơ như đã la thử ví dụ thế bánh ngọt Thôi anh đánh Ngọc thì chắc không có đá
và cũng không có được ừ ừ thì nhưng mà là bởi vì cái ra tao bay Em
đang nói là Ý tôi là tôi chỉ bán đồ uống rồi các bạn mà chỉ ví dụ chỉ bán trà sữa đấy ạ thì
mấy cái này hiện tại thì về cơ bản vẫn đang phù hợp vẫn được làm đúng không Thì
là thế nên là anh ấy thì nghĩa nhìn vào một cái dp mà nó vẫn áp dụng được và về
sau giờ sự là mình tính việc là 5 năm hoặc 10 năm nữa thì nó còn dùng được không nó chạm một cái DB là như thế thì
hiện tại thì lên bé của em mà vẫn dùng được Nếu mà không có gì thay đổi thì chắc là anh anh nghĩ là không sao trong
trường hợp này cho ông xã rồi đã mình sẽ để modi thôi vợ demo thì hiện tại sẽ tắt
Xem màn hình để bạn vỗ có thể để mua phần khách hàng à
Ừ tao mới
thôi nghỉ ở Mở bản đồ anh
alo em Ừ để mua để mua em ơi
ê ê
à à ở đây là giao diện chính của vff có Slider
Cho xem cách sản phẩm và có phát triển nhảy à
ừ ừ à à
anh ấy cũng có trời chứa các thông tin em
thử đăng ký ah ừ ừ
à à
ừ ừ
em bị em bị mất cái chia sẻ màn hình rồi à
đi học à
anh mất từ lúc nào đàn Giang à
anh không vừa vừa gửi xong rồi vừa xong rồi à Ừ
ok ok rồi tiếp đi ạ
à à Mỹ Tâm Linh 01 lệ thì ta sẽ
để báo lỗi à ừ ừ
ừ ừ
à à à à
à à Ừ anh tết nhà em thích các em Anh quên trở
lại à à à
ừ ừ Anh đi làm đây là tính năng đăng nhập
anh có sử dụng tz à
ừ ừ
em gửi tài khoản có thể sửa không có thể hiện sự thông tin à
bí mật khẩu mới ngày nhưng để chống thì sẽ bao nhiêu là không đổi còn mật khẩu cũ
lúc nào có nhập để có thể gửi thông tin à
à à
đi vệ sinh ra khỏi
chỉ cần gọi dân chủ là có thể xem các nhà sản phẩm
có lẽ Xem theo thể loại ừ ừ
đã tìm ra tiêu hóa
[Vỗ tay] sẽ không tìm thấy sản phẩm nào sẽ dòng
chữ này để xem ở
Ừ OK OK để mô hẳn đặt bạn đơn sau đó thì sang
bên admin duyệt thủ đô nào như thế là không ngăn nổi duyệt đúng nhỉ à
em tắt bắt thử anh giờ Lát nữa em có thể bật thử và diệc lại bên At least Ok Để
anh muốn xem rồi đô nó sẽ trông như ạ ạ
à à à à ừ ừ
anh em song ạ ạ mở ra để mua của em này đúng nghĩa để mua
em không nói gì mấy không không bù cho ông kia kia nói như đa cấp vậy nhưng không sao à
Ừ thật ra là thuyết trình thì đố kỵ lập trình viên mình không cần phải nói nhiều lắm cũng nói qua là không không cần phải
nói nhất thiết lại Bây giờ em sẽ nhập cái này bây giờ em bị bầm cái đâu mà chỉ cần nói qua là bây giờ em sẽ để mô tình
năng ABC sau đó Thì cứ làm một loạt rồi sau đó thì tại sao nó lại hiển thị ra
như này để như thế cũng được đẩy xuống kinh nghiệm về cái á cách để mô Ok bạn ạ Bạn kia để mua vé đá
mini bây giờ vợ Player MC the first dhmobile admin
hết hả sẽ đăng nhập vào tài khoản là quản lý ai gọi là sức admin
Tại sao lại không nhanh Chắc do cửa sổ
đang bị rung lên ok thì trong này để có thể giúp wi-fi có
thể chỉnh sửa các thông tin như là chính phường tại đại diện ở đây
chỉnh sửa thông tin chỉ cần học thì đây sẽ kiểm tra lại về
mật khẩu xem có đúng hiện tại hay không hay Cái này nó có cùng với nhau hay
không bình tĩnh bình tĩnh Em làm trong cái bán hàng thì em đem vô tình đó em còn đã
thật là quan trọng với bên bán hàng chưa là phải thế chắc là phải đặt hàng trước
chứ nhỉ Giờ em em đặt hàng nhanh được thường các bạn bấm các bạn cũng nên
chuẩn bị trước có sẵn sản phẩm có sẵn đơn để mà đề mô có từ thứ cho tiện
nhìn cảm với đầu đi
chợ sẽ đặt thử à
ở đây là đơn vừa mới đặt đặt thì nó sẽ
thực hiện lên đầu tiên nó sẽ hiện theo thứ tự thời gian mới nhất mình có thể ấn
vào đây để xem thông tin nhưng mà thấy đây là sẽ có đầy đủ thông
tin về người đập số điện thoại địa chỉ ở thời gian mua trong đất kiếp sân này sẽ
lưu thông tin của người nhận và có thể duyệt đơn ở đây thì duyệt đơn
thì sẽ có chưa bắt đầu nó đang ở bên đây thì có thể là ex-f
khi mà nó lại hét rồi thì có thể làm mát and delivery tại Dallas thì cái này là
khi ở Bình giao hàng thành công ấy thì mình sẽ được để mình sẽ diệt ở đây hết Tự động chuyển sang là ai đi bơi thì
không Khi mà đã ra được rồi sao không thấy đơn nữa à
Ở đâu Ở đâu ở đây thì đó delivers A
chỗ này chỗ này xem ra đi mua à nhà mình có thể trực tiếp mình có thể
trực tiếp duyệt đơn ở đây ok ok bình tĩnh bình tĩnh bình tĩnh
cái đơn kia đến 54 Đúng không Nó đã chuyển thành đây vợ như mình cũng giật
em em kéo xuống thì em xuống có đơn pending kia đúng không em bấm vào anh
xem đơn bên đấy một cái đơn đến mình access ở đây không không không không
ạ Cái sau đó thì em kéo cao lên chứ
cách tắt chuột phải chưa phải để ZicZac others
ở đấy thôi Ờ copy ở đây à nút à ấn nút
đúng không Đây là sân s đây Ừ không sao ấn nữa inspect đi nice-pic
Anh ở Network a Network
xe tải mjz lên đi Ừ nó đi đó đây
anh em không xử lý được cái phần này là thời
gian nó hơi cái đẹp nên em chọn cách làm đi nó ra ấn ấn quay lại shipping order đi
Anh hiểu vấn đề rồi bây bây giờ giả thử em ở bảo là không
thể lập liên tục không là nó đi nốt không không không phải ấn quay lại bên
Trang à đấy anh Anh đang muốn thử là em vừa bảo là không thể hủy được đơn đã đã đi vơ đúng
không Để anh thử copy copy cái đường dẫn để mà thực ra là như thế thì vẫn vẫn có
thể xử lý được tại vì bên bên kia em không có thật sẽ được bên phần xử lý là không có thật sẽ đấy không không kiểm
tra nó là bạn không có kiểm tra cũng chỉ có người dùng thì không không phát hiện thấy nó cho người dùng nữa Thật à Thế à
trước đây em cũng có thể sẽ nói về cái trạng thái kết tinh được thì mình nhập cái tơ là panda người trên đây ở
những hiện nghĩa là kiểu của mình copy đường dẫn và thay đổi ID của order thì
được mình vẫn có thể đổi được tình trạng của một đơn bất kỳ đúng không Và vì virus ở bên p vẫn chưa kiểm tra đúng
không Dạ Bạn mới chỉ ẩn đi ở bên file đúng không ạ
Thế đấy Thì anh đang nói thử có những cái bốc và các bạn có thể bị dính là như
thế Ok Hồ em còn tính năng gì nữa không nhỉ em gọi điện có thể sánh được rồi nhá
Superman thôi không không không không không nên cho xóa đơn thả vợ
mình Đây là bộ lọc hóa đơn Xin chào bạn ơi em có thể trả lại sao ạ
ở đây là lập mà nó anh tìm về quá thì được ngay đi
Ừ Ok con còn cái gì nữa nhỉ bên ngô Đắc
thì có thể là thêm sản phẩm ở à mình để môi luôn sản phẩm đây không
không ơi nhớ mà có trường hợp nào mà đạt cái sản phẩm này thôi thôi người dùng sửa
lại sản phẩm này có thể nhân viên nó bị lỗi nó sửa sản phẩm này thì những thì
cái đơn mà đang đặt rõ có bị ảnh hưởng không có kiểu đó em có bị sao
Ừ nếu mà mình update một cái sản phẩm mà đã được nạp điện thì có khả năng là nó
sẽ bị sửa theo với cái đơn Tại vì em không có khách nữa à Anh nói đều đối với nhau bằng tài khóa
mà cái đi lên là nó sẽ gì dính với nhau như vậy nữa Ừ nhưng mà anh là nói sửa móng chân thôi thì cái đơn cũ có bị ảnh
hưởng ở cơ sở mình khóa đá mày có đá thì phải gọi cho cái đơn nó nó
nó làm sao cái đơn nó thư và một cái đơn
kéo sân đây nó sẽ không bị sửa đây đất cái đó nó bị sao biết được phá cái đáng
để cho nữa thì nó vẫn ghi là 500k Ok anh hỏi cái lỗi sợ vợ kể cái này thật
ra liên quan thì cái vụ mà vừa nãy có bạn bảo ý đó là khi mà em tách ra một cái một cái bảng riêng người có option
khi mà cập cập thứ mình không cho phép cập nhật Cái này luôn nhớ là sự mà đã đã
nối xanh hóa đơn chi tiết rồi Còn bây giờ em đang lưu lại là lưu lại theo cột và cũng không nối xong là đơn chi tiết
thành ra là khi mà em sửa về áp chuẩn này thì cái hóa đơn chi tiết nó không để ngược và nó không báo lỗi gì cả đúng
không thành đấy Bế về cái chặt chẽ về cái mắt cơ sở dữ liệu thì thôi không sao
chắc là cũng ở trường hợp hi hữu nào xảy ra như thế nào Okay cho mình mấy sửa thì
cái kia không chỉ là một cái nốt đây là nó không bị sửa heo đúng rồi nó là dạng tách nó không không bị can thiệp thì cả
đúng không có dạng bộ khóa rồi lấy cả cái này thì cũng có xóa và ăn tết
nên khách mời cũng vậy bây giờ mới có thể tại vì nó không để avatar nó không
hiện ở đây ok ok con còn tính năng gì nó con nhái em tính năng này chắc là vậy thôi Ok
Thôi cảm ơn các bạn ở bên admin thì admin sẽ có quyền thế là delete và không
có kiểm tra lại ở bên phần xử lý đó là đấy mà có là chỉ chuột cả ID đó là admin
Nam đã thì cũng không thì sợ nữa à À thế à tin tức là mình có nhập cái ID
ở trên đường dẫn là admin thì nó cũng khám phá lại tức là mày không được không được quyền chỉnh sửa là khóa và xóa cái
tài khoản quá đi nữa thì cũng chẳng phải là PIN Nó xóa được bản thân mình xe tải bản thân mình cũng không bạn Tại
vì nếu mà jean của nó là thuốc admin admin FC sợ rồi thì không Không có làm gì hết thì super super nin có thể xóa
được bản thân mình không cũng không thể đâu Em thử bấm Em thử copy đường dẫn xóa
rồi em thay và ngay đi bạn thân này Ừ để xem sự kể Chi Dân
xe Cha đưa kế điện tử mà à
anh em đã kiểm tra đoạn này đâu đúng không Nói theo Chưa kiểm tra siêu kiểm
tra xóa được mà Có ai đi bằng bằng một ngon
cha mẹ à à Không xóa luôn ra được những là có
kiểm tra karaoke Nhớ Thực ra còn những cái nữa Thực ra vẫn có thể còn những
ngày nữa vẫn phải bấm thêm cái này quan cái này em cho cái thời gian em làm tao
cũng hơi ngắn Đây là cái phần Valdes em không bị chặt chẽ lắm em tự đánh giá là như vậy Ừ nhưng mà anh đã nói chung các
nhóm khác đấy các nhóm khác kiểu gì cũng sẽ có vài nhóm có thể Dính vào mấy cái lỗi có thể xóa được bản thân là người
này có thể sửa được người kia rồi ngon có thể xóa đơn hàng thay đổi tình trạng
đơn mà đã được duyệt này Đấy Ok thôi Cảm ơn nhóm em nghỉ cả đấy ạ
cho phép những tắt xe màn hình ok ok [âm nhạc]
nhóm 1 có đây không nhỉ bảo vệ đốt quả cuối rồi mình nhỉ nhỉ Bây giờ con à
Ừ thôi bảo vệ cho xong đi rồi nhỉ đúng không ạ ừ ừ
Ừ thế giờ em chụp hình Ờ Ờ bạn cùng nhóm cũng có đây rồi à à
Không em em là một mình đúng không Dạ không em điểm Ừ Ok Ok em trình bày đi
à à
anh cảm thấy mình quen chưa ừ rồi rồi Em bận bắt đầu đi
Dạ em chào thầy và các bạn thì hôm nay em sẽ trình bày các website của em về
quản lý một shop bánh gia đình ngắm em là nhóm mộc mà có thành
viên là em thì lý do em chọn đề tài là do thói quen
của người dùng hiện tại là khách hàng thay đổi thì người ta từ việc mua bán
trực tiếp thì người ta thích thích việc mua bán online hơn thì người ta thường là xem chút thông tin và
em kiểm tra sản phẩm trên internet và website hơn rồi người
ta mới mua Ê bà cũng là do xu hướng không hiện tại là nó đang chuyển đổi số thì các doanh
nghiệp cửa hàng từ từ nhỏ đến lớn đều chuyển sang cứ Hướng Online để
thích ứng với người dùng hơn và để cấp thể phát triển hơn
Ừ Thì đó tất cả người dùng của em là có khách hàng hiện nay khách hàng có tài
khoản nhân viên và quản lý thì khách hàng bản like thì sẽ có chức năng là
đăng ký để sản phẩm Xem chi tiết sản phẩm Xem phim sẽ xóa giữa hành khách có
tài khoản thì sẽ có đầy đủ chức năng chức năng của khách hàng thông thường và để nhập sản xuất đặt hàng Xem lịch sử
mua hàng và đặc biệt là sẽ có chế độ khuyến mãi cho
ý cho Chuyển khách hàng của tài khoản là sẽ được giảm mo phần trăm theo hóa đơn
mẫu hóa đơn và ở nhân viên nhân viên bán hàng thì sẽ
có chức năng là đăng nhập đăng xuất sẽ thêm sự số sản phẩm để thay đổi tình trạng ngân hàng là việc
hủy hóa đơn xem thêm sửa Xóa thông tin khách hàng họ không xem sửa Xóa thông
tin khách hàng mà anh cũng theo bà quản lý thì sẽ có đầy
đủ chức năng của nhân viên thông thường đem theo xóa hai loại nhắn tin thì xóa
nhân viên và chỉnh sửa Chính sách giảm giá á
anh ở đây là sơ đồ quan hệ thực thể của em em thì nhân viên nhân viên thể thì sẽ
có thể diệt được nhiều hóa đơn Ừ thế hoặc khách hàng sẽ được không Hàng
sẽ được sẽ đạt được nhiều những hóa đơn thì hóa đơn sẽ chủ nhiều sản phẩm
mã sản phẩm sẽ lục-lò mà phải loại bạn lại thì thể loại có nhiều sản phẩm
sản phẩm sẽ thuộc sẽ được đặt bỏ nhiều hóa đơn
em về hóa đơn sẽ được Việt Chỉ bởi một nhân viên không Ừ ok quay quay quay quay lại quay lại
con lại một tí được ạ Bây giờ là để riêng nhỏ mem anh hỏi cái này ờ Tại sao em em vừa nói là một
hóa đơn có bao nhiêu sản phẩm nghỉ à nhà hàng hóa đơn để có một hộp nhiều sản
phẩm chỉ có một hoặc nhiều sản phẩm và một sản phẩm thì thuộc bao nhiêu hóa đơn
Đã hoạt động 1 sản phẩm sẽ chỉ được một hóa đơn mua sản phẩm thì thuộc hóa đơn
sẽ được đặt ở nhiều hóa đơn anh Tại sao được thật nhiều nhé á à à
ạ bây giờ sư của anh đặt hai con iPhone thì hai con iPhone này
thuộc về anh hay là thuộc về cả hóa đơn của thằng khác nữa
ăn củ cả người khác nha hai con iPhone này cũng của chùa người khác được đã Tại sao
Ý của em là sản phẩm này sẽ được đặt bởi nhiều khách hàng mà
mà khách hàng đặt nó chỉ làm trong một hóa đơn của một
khách hàng anh em có không không không Bởi vì chính vì
các bạn đang bị cái cái các bạn dùng từ sản phẩm đấy hãy ra là các bạn sẽ bị
nhầm khi mà trả lời câu hỏi đấy là đương nhiên là một hóa đơn có nhiều sản phẩm
và một sản phẩm thì chỉ thuộc một hóa đơn thì nó mới đúng con nếu mà mặt hàng
sản phẩm thì mới gọi là một mặt hàng sản phẩm có thể có trong nhiều hóa đơn thì
nó mới chuẩn ví dụ Giả sử là anh vừa nói anh mua con hay hai con iPhone đúng
không Thì hai con iPhone đấy chỉ thuộc cái hóa đơn của anh thôi không thuộc họ đơn hàng nào cả nhưng mà cái loại iPhone
đấy thì người ta vẫn sẽ vẫn bán chứ không có chuyện giới hạn gì cả đúng không Không chuyện mua người này mua
người kia không được mua nữa nó vẫn sẽ được bán và cái ID của hóa đơn của cái
sản phẩm ở đây vẫn có thể nằm trong lá đơn người khác đấy nghĩa là mặt hàng thì
hiểu đúng đấy thì cái này là anh hỏi để cho các
bạn cũng rút kinh nghiệm thôi con trình bày ra trình bày như em vừa rồi cũng được rồi nhưng mà hỏi cái tắc cái
mình mình mình trình bày giờ mình phải biết biết tại sao nói thế đúng không Okay tiếp
và tiếp tới là sơ đồ cơ sở dữ liệu của ngắm em thì đây sẽ có bệnh nhân viên để
chứa thông tin của nhân viên cho khách hàng để chứa thông tin của khách hàng thì ở đây em có tốc độ này và
nó liên kết với bạn giảm giá thì từ đem lấy được phần trăm để đó em
à Hấp dụng vào chính sách khuyến mãi cho khách hàng có tài khoản
à mà ở đây em có bạn sản phẩm thì phải sản phẩm sẽ nói với
bạn hóa đơn chi tiết và bản hóa đơn thì bạn hóa đơn chi tiết sẽ có mã hóa đơn mà
sản phẩm số lượng và diệt bởi nhân viên nào ạ Và ở đây bản hóa đơn em có
cột trạng thái để sử dụng cho chức năng chìa khóa đơn của nhân viên
anh ở đây là bạn thấy loại để chứa tên Thúy loại A
kết quả bóng quay lại quay lại 1 tỉ trở lại chị Ẩm Thực ra là
ờ ờ em có hai cái thân họ đã thống nhất à
hóa đơn chi tiết có thêm cột duyệt bởi là ai người duyệt đúng không
phụ nữ mông mà tại sao em giá cổ phiếu hả
Nó sẽ chưa tuần của nhân viên thông thường mà mình sẽ lưu lại ID ở nhân viên
để đổi sang tiện hơn này à ạ Và nếu em muốn lấy tên này được ra là có
thể đấy thì nối xanh bởi Android lấy tên cũng được và trừ khi em không muốn roi
thì em phải lưu lại theo tên thôi nhưng mà chỗ này là em sẽ lấy buồn Jackson
toàn của nhân viên à ừ ừ cho cả thế cũng được cũng là một cách để đỡ phải do đúng không Ok nhưng
mà tại sao lại không nhân viên lại đi diệt hóa đơn chi tiết đó phải duyệt hóa đơn đấy nhỉ
anh Hay em muốn làm duyệt theo kiểu duyệt từng sản phẩm 1
anh không Em chỉ diệt được một lần nữa vì một lần luôn thấy em phải đi mua trên
xem nếu thế phải diệt trong hóa đơn mới đúng chứ nhỉ đúng không Bởi vì cả hóa đơn mà
Ừ cái này chắc bị nhầm rồi không em còn nếu mà em muốn duyệt từng sản phẩm một sự là một cái hóa đơn đấy Đạt 3
sản phẩm nhưng mà phải kiểm tra từng sản phẩm Một xem có đọc được sản phẩm nói
không chọn loại bỏ sản phẩm mới đi thì thì mới là duyệt bởi tâm từng cái sản
phẩm trong hóa đơn thì nó hợp lý Ừ cái này là cả hóa đơn của em luôn
cột đầy bị nhầm bị nhầm BN đúng không đoạn này sửa thì cũng nhanh thôi
Ừ ok Ở đây có các bạn kia đang bản khá sôi xơ nổi về vụ giảm giá em Em thử nói
qua về cái vụ giám sát được những lá này là em cho thích cậu cấp độ
này ở bên khách hàng là một em chưa có phát triển trở thành một cái bảng rồi em
sẽ phát triển thành các bạn riêng Để em lưu em lưu thông tin từ khuyến mãi
ở góc có bản giảm giá để làm gì nữ hoàng nhạc à
à Dạ em hiện tại là chỉ có cấp độ 1 thôi à à
cho em Em định phát triển như nào thử nói qua xem
ở lò cho khách hàng nó sẽ chia từ từng
loại giống như lời bên shopee với anh thể loại vàng thể loại kim cương rồi
à à về giá rẻ cung cấp cho khách hàng à
ở đoạn này chưa làm đó đoạn ở chỗ làm hiện trường Ok Thế đi anh bảo đấy Cái gì
trở lại mình cứ tạm mà khỏi sợ like nhé ok rồi Chắc thế thôi ngoài cái đấy ra
chắc giống các bạn hết rồi Ừ ok xanh để mua đẹp
à à à à
ở biển xe đi mua xe khách hàng của em
à Thế bây giờ em sẽ thử hàng thì em đăng nhập đăng nhập với
chế độ cắt like à à
à à ừ ừ à à
à à à à
à à ở chỗ này em chưa có xe đó à
bộ phim sex qua bên Anime à
ừ ừ à à
à à anh ở đây là cái đơn mà em vừa đó
từ hôm nay em sẽ lo Xem chi tiết về hóa đơn khách bấm vào cái mã
phim hoạt hình sẽ biết được cái người đặt là ai cho ví dụ khách hàng có tài khoản thì nó
sẽ hiện tên ra còn không thì chỉ hiện các bạn like không em à Ok thường diệt
anh đơn đấy chứ Âm Nhạc du
lịch đến đây phạm hiệu báo rẽ bên Bé chị xuống này ở bến khách hàng có xem lại đơn mình đã
chưa đâu Ừ nếu mà cách khắc có tài khoản thì xem được anh
khi đến đăng nhập Thôi bỏ qua đi sang lại Vinamilk khách hàng thì anh
thấy ở làm cũng tương đối rồi em muốn để mô gì tính nam đến khách hàng nữa không ngoài xem đơn đó
Ừ vậy anh có thể tìm kiếm sản phẩm Tìm
kiếm rồi à trò chuyện một tìm kiếm bánh mì Ý
Ừ ok đây
anh khách hàng này đặt được đơn nào chưa nhỏ Xem xem thử hay là Đạt đơn mà việc
như có em có được sử mua hàng cá nhân biển xanh
anh em phim sex có thể xem được chi tiết của
đơn hàng ok rồi có hẹn cả người Việt không à Rồi
ừ ừ có vợ xem được đơn người khác không à Dạ không Không nhớ mà Em thử bấm vào
giờ em thay đổi mã đi anh nghĩa là em chưa kiểm tra vụ đấy đâu anh đúng không ạ
khi bé Em ngủ chưa Em nhập mã là 41 rồi mà cái đơn của cái khách vãng lai đặt đấy
đấy đúng không Mình chưa kiểm tra vụ này đấy Hai Anh nghĩa là một mình mà kiểu gì
mấy cái vụ hoa Tết thì ra là chưa Chưa Nghĩ đến chỉ mới làm xong ra đi để anh chưa làm kỹ lắm từ cha Thủy mới làm xong
tình năm thôi đấy nghĩa khách hàng cũng hỏi vài vết cái thử đúng không hỏi bên mỗi admin gas
mini từ vài đến nó không cần cầu kỳ Nếu khách hàng của Wellness phát thùy mị hơn
Ê mày đấy em có về đi Tao quên là đăng ký
ừ ừ à à Ừ thôi ở bên anh có nên ăn mini hạn quay
qua lại vừa ăn mì đi
Ừ ừ khuyến mãi nằm ở đây sẽ khuyến mãi lòng chúng ta chưa Làm gì
đúng không anh em cho chỉnh sửa được lo phần trăm khuyến mãi cho khách hàng của tài khoản không nhớ mà đã làm gì và phần trăm mà
giờ đã đã tính toán tính theo khuyến mãi rồi à
Ừ ừ nếu có tính hiệu điện thoại trên xem đó thôi
Ok cứ cho khuyến mãi được rồi nhưng mà khi mà em tình yêu khuyến mãi thì em lại
phải lưu lại cái giá đã khuyến mãi ở trong hóa đơn cơ để sau làm đồng quê nữa
thì nên là cái đoạn đấy em lại thiếu hiểu thế mà em muốn làm khuyến mãi
Ừ Ok thôi Tại anh nghĩa tạm đủ toàn bộ
tính năng cơ bản rồi có nâng cao kiểu dạng mà Iraq hay ở thống kê gì không nhỉ
à Dạ con hình ảnh chưa làm thì thôi không sao thế sẽ ổn phết rồi đấy
chính là giao diện đẹp hơn của anh lắm Thôi cảm ơn bạn nhé
ừ ừ xã hội
Ừ ok thì ỉa sao buổi hôm nay thì các bạn thấy là
à Cái nhóm về cơ bản thì giao diện vẫn khác đẹp ở đấy thì nhất Thứ hai là hôm
nay thì mình đã hỏi anh những câu mới đúng không Các bạn thấy có thể vài bạn
sẽ run đấy nếu mà kiểu Nếu mà thầy hỏi mình câu lấy chắc
mình cũng chết ấy trợ hệ các bạn sẽ phải cẩn thận mấy cái vụ bác bác em virus của
vì mình fans và đấy thì nó chị gần nhở cho có thôi nếu mà ông là một nách Thứ
hai là mình có góp ý cũng vài cái về tài liệu các thứ thử rồi Các bạn thấy mình không
quan tâm thì rửa các bạn là thuyết trình run thế nào hay là như nào đấy Mình không quan trọng các bạn miễn là sẵn là
nói anh là được đừng có nghĩa ông kia rồi nãy ông ấy hơi ít nói một tí thì
giúp cái nhiệm vụ đấy thôi các bạn cần nói nói này không quan trọng việc nói
hay như thế nào đấy miễn nói Trình bày được ý tưởng của mình làm được rồi thế
được công nhận rồi mình sẽ gửi các bạn phải không chấm điểm sau để các bạn biết
được là có các bạn cần có dịp nó có cả vụ chấm thuyết trình ơi nhá Ngôi chợ biết trình đây tôi không chậm nói cái vụ
cho trại không bởi dân công nghệ mình không chấm qua rồi đấy à Ừ cái làm á Làm cái này nhựa hơn ba
tháng thì vậy đúng không rằm tháng 10 mới ba tháng không tính nghỉ Tết đi 3 4
tháng gì đấy vừa học vừa làm đúng không ông này nói chung là về cơ bản mình thấy
khá đã tồi cá nhỏ hôm nay và cả hôm trước nữa nếu mà chấm thì sẽ đều được
qua rồi đấy nên là không cần phải sửa code hay gì cả thôi về đón một thì mình
không khắt khe lắm chỉ cần làm đầy đủ tính nam thêm được xá là qua rồi mà không như đồ ăn hay thì sẽ rất là khắt
khe Ở Nơi Nào các bạn cứ sẵn sàng tâm lý chưa gửi luôn hai của đồ
án một thì cứ thoải mái đi ạ Thế nhá sẽ bữa hôm nay thế thôi cũng phải tiếng rồi
Ừ thôi tạm nghỉ nhé Chào bạn nha à